hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 29 hört zu und spricht nach
michael ist in der schule michael ist in
der schule
tina ist im kino
tina ist im kino fred kauft im
supermarkt ein
fred kauft im supermarkt ein
lisa liegt im bett lisa liegt im bett
aline wartet an der bushaltestelle aline
wartet an der bushaltestelle
tomas ist in den bergen
anton ist in den ferien an ton ist in
den ferien
das bild hängt an der wand
das bild hängt an der wand der fernseher
steht vor dem sofa der fernseher steht
vor dem sofa die katze liegt unter dem
stuhl
die katze liegt unter dem stuhl
das handy liegt auf dem tisch
die steckdose ist neben der tür die
steckdose ist neben der tür das auto
steht in der garage das auto steht in
der garage
die lampe hängt über dem tisch die lampe
hängt über dem tisch weißt du wo mein
schlüssel ist weißt du wo mein schlüssel
ist ja er liegt auf dem sofa
er liegt auf dem sofa
weißt du wo meine jacke ist weißt du wo
meine jacke ist
ja sie hängt im kleiderschrank
sie hängt im kleiderschrank weißt du wo
mein handy ist weißt du wo mein handy
ist es liegt neben dem bett
[Musik]
es liegt neben dem bett
weißt du wo meine schuhe sind
weißt du wo meine schuhe sind ja sie
stehen vor der tür
sie stehen vor der tür
weißt du wo weißt du wo
nein ich habe keine ahnung
nein ich weiß es nicht
tut mir leid ich weiß es nicht tut mir
leid ich weiß es nicht tut mir leid ich
kann dir nicht helfen tut mir leid ich
kann ihnen nicht helfen tut mir leid ich
kann ihnen nicht helfen
im park kann man spazieren im park kann
man spazieren am bankautomat kann man
geld abheben am bankautomaten geld
abheben
in der die
so kann man tanzen in der disco kann man
tanzen an der bar kann man ein getränk
trinken an der bar kann man ein getränk
trinken im supermarkt kann man
lebensmittel einkaufen im supermarkt
kann man lebensmittel einkaufen an der
tankstelle kann man benzin tanken an der
tankstelle kann man benzin tanken im
parkhaus kann man das auto parkieren im
fitnesscenter kann man trainieren im fit
center kann man trainieren
die autos fahren auf der straße die
autos fahren auf der straße
ich beschreibe mein wohnzimmer in meinem
wohnzimmer gibt es eine tür
und ein fenster
in der mitte vom
und 10 steht ein fernseher
über den
sehr hängt eine lampe
vor dem fenster steht ein schreibtisch
der schreibtisch steht vor dem fenster
vor dem schreibtisch steht ein stuhl der
stuhl steht vor dem schreibtisch
rechts neben der tür hängt ein bild an
der wand
das bild hängt rechts neben der tür an
der wand zwischen dem schreibtisch und
der tür steht eine pflanze die pflanze
steht zwischen dem schreibtisch und der
tür zwischen dem fernseher und der tür
liegt ein teppich auf dem boden der
teppich liegt zwischen dem fernseher um
der tür auf dem boden
fenster steht ein regal das regal steht
neben dem fenster im regal stehen bücher
die bücher stehen im regal
an der wand steht ein sofa das sofa
stets an der wand über dem sofa hängt
eine uhr
die uhr hängt über dem sofa
vor dem sofa steht ein kleiner tisch der
kleine tisch steht vor dem sofa
auf dem sofa schläft eine katze die
katze schläft auf dem sofa